rice a simple wash of the hands first
off quickly wet the hands just lightly
and then from there a nice dose of soap
from there literally rub into the parlor
hands throughout the outside of the
inside then very carefully at your hands
and lock them in between like that and
just literally rub them up and down
horizontally and vertically up and down
then engage the thumbs twist the therms
around and then very quickly wash the
back of your hands landing on your
fingers now you can get in underneath
those fingernails take one thumb and
slide it across your nails across times
like this is really important here those
nails very short trust me they do look
very cool short and that's thoughts any
bacteria growing now look we've got that
really nice heavy larva foam again a
nice brisk rub take it to about two
inches just above your wrists and then
from there look a quick rinse up down a
good shake really important to shape
them well and then take a little towel
now over these next coming weeks
try not to engage when stone hello to
people because trust me a nice big smile
goes a long way